the united states has urged russia to
declare that it has no intention of
invading ukraine speaking at the u.n
security council u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken repeated warnings that
russia is poised to launch an attack
russia insisted that it is withdrawing
troops and accused ukraine of failing to
implement a previous peace deal
meanwhile there are reports of fighting
in ukraine's east with the government
and pro-russia separatists accusing each
other of carrying out shelling attacks
in this government-held village in
eastern ukraine a kindergarten hit by a
shell
the ukrainian army says the shell that
was fired from the other side hit just
into this kindergarten there where you
can see this hole in the wall and it
fell into
the place where the kids were going to
have their gym class luckily none of the
kids was inside that room
children were having breakfast at the
time and were planning to have lessons
in that room at 9 00 am according to
their schedule
luckily the children were not heard only
the employees were shell-shocked
u.s president joe biden believes a
russian invasion will take place any day
now they have not moved any of their
church out they've moved more troops in
number one number two
we have reason to believe that they are
engaged in a false flag operation to
have an excuse to go in
every indication we have is they're
prepared to go into a train attack
ukraine
at a un security council meeting u.s
secretary of state anthony blinken
warned russia was already manufacturing
a provocation to justify an attack
this could be a violent event that
russia will bring on ukraine or an
outrageous accusation that russia will
level against the ukrainian government
moscow has already accused ukraine of
committing genocide in the eastern
donbass region and labeled the false
flag claims as hysteria
nobody seeks any excuses
for hostile elections
we said we do not have any intention to
do this
for days russia has said its troops are
withdrawing from areas near the border
with ukraine but the west believes
moscow has amassed some 150 000 soldiers
around its neighbor the conflict is far
from over
dw correspondent matthias bullinger is
in eastern ukraine in the town of
kramatorsk near the front line in the
conflict between government forces and
russia-backed separatists i asked him if
the shelling of the nursery that he
pointed out in his report was a sign
that tensions in the region are growing
yes tensions are growing that's what we
can say for sure there has been intense
shelling for two days now uh after we
left that place where the kindergarten
is there the place was shelled again and
uh houses were destroyed and were on
fire at night
and the same is reported from other
places villages and towns along the
contact line
so there's a clear escalation here the
ukrainian side blames it all on the
other side on the separatist separatist
side and there is a lot of conflicting
information the uosc has not established
yet uh all of the uh details for for
these fires i have often uh just
refrained from uh clearly stating or or
have not been able to to clearly say
where it was coming from but what what
is very clear is that shelling has
intensified on this
on this side of the of the border
shelling uh on ukrainian villages we
have less information from the other
side
right so there where you are in the east
of ukraine that's a place where the
fighting never really stopped are people
there afraid of a wider russian invasion
people here are afraid of an escalation
of an intensifying of fighting here as
you said it has never stopped its there
has been fighting for eight years
although at times ceasefires
were in place and they were respected at
times they were violated only slightly
and now we are seeing this escalation
the prospect of a wider invasion that
would include many other parts of
ukraine that would for example include
an incursion from the north
onto kiev for example that is something
of course people in other parts of
ukraine are worried about however uh the
worries uh here in ukraine do not match
the international warnings the ukrainian
government has said once again that they
do not see preparations on the russian
side for a full-scale invasion
and
the people are just
watching this carefully
they are alert but they are not
panicking
and there's this dispute about whether
russia really has pulled some of its
troop back from its border with ukraine
what's your understanding of what's
going on
well it seems that this has not really
happened when they announced the
withdrawal of troops there was some
activity troops were being moved around
but
the first thing is that russia said it
would move back
to the troops from the western
military district that is those places
that are anyway close to the ukrainian
borders back into their
into their barracks but they could be
deployed quickly again now what we are
hearing from intelligence sources is
that they have not really withdrawn many
they have moved them a little bit around
but not withdrawn some are even saying
the u.s have even said that they might
have reinforced them or this is based on
satellite imagery uh there is no
headcount of course of soldiers
no headcount accessible uh to anybody
else but the russian leadership of the
soldiers that are really deployed there
okay thank you for that matthias dw
correspondent matthias bullinger in
eastern ukraine
let's talk to ian lesser who's vice
president of the american public policy
think tank the german marshall fund
we'll talk about the the the problems on
ukraine's border he joins us from
brussels welcome to dw um people are
fond of saying that diplomacy is working
as long as no one is shooting but it's
hard to see
what the last few weeks of intense high
level
diplomacy has achieved
well that's exactly right uh of course
the diplomacy is essential but the
dynamics change as time has gone on and
as forces have been concentrated around
ukraine as the risk of something going
seriously wrong whatever russian
intentions are uh will increase and so
uh there are two
challenges here one is crisis management
immediate crisis management which so far
does not seem to have been successful
and the other is to see if there isn't
some way uh
to
talk to russia about some of its
longer-term concerns i mean president
macron has tried to do that that too has
not yet been successful and that's a
longer-term project
so
there seems to be little trust in this
process as well when we have russia
saying that it's withdrawing troops and
the u.s saying and its allies saying
well we've checked and you really
haven't again
it's hard to see how diplomacy can work
without trust
there's very very little trust i mean
that's that's absolutely clear
what is also clear is that it's possible
to see almost everything intelligence
services even commercial satellite
operators can provide uh overhead
imagery which makes you know in other
kinds of intelligence being gathered
makes it very clear what is happening
but we're judging intentions
is much tougher and there we really do
get to this question of trust and trust
at the moment is i don't know if it's at
rock bottom but it's certainly at a
minimum on both sides
and talking about addressing russia's
security concerns that
cynically speaking if russia wants to
keep uh
ukraine out of nato then short of nato
or ukraine agreeing to this demand then
all moscow really has to do is maintain
the instability at the border
is that a sustainable policy in the long
term
well i have to think that russia
understands very well that nato that
ukraine is not becoming a member of nato
anytime soon perhaps never i mean this
is very clear it's one thing to have a
declaratory open door of
which is nato policy nato allies aren't
going to back away from that but the
politics of it are also very clear that
nato simply isn't joining uh sorry
ukraine isn't joining nato anytime soon
they may be equally concerned over the
long term of ukraine just simply coming
closer to
the european union coming closer to the
west and all that that would mean for
society and politics inside russia
itself and that may be the longer
concern the longer game that russia is
trying to play to prevent that uh you
know it's pretty clear that the the
tougher they can make the situation look
in ukraine the harder it will be for
ukraine to be
integrated into the west right and
what's your view on the way that u.s
european cooperation in this situation
has worked is this a well functioning
machine
i think it's been very very close
actually and you know there will be
there's a package of sanctions being
developed on the european side but
developed in close coordination with the
united states these haven't been
revealed in detail yet but my sense is
that on on a an hourly basis a constant
basis the eu and the us are talking to
each other about what should be in that
package and about policy towards ukraine
in general it's it's a huge shift from
the kind of atmosphere we had in u.s eu
relations just a few years ago obviously
all right good talking thank you so much
for joining us ian lesser vice president
of the german marshall fund
good to be with you
well the ukraine crisis is expected to
dominate the munich security conference
which begins today u.s vice president
kamala harris is one of the first
foreign representatives to arrive in
germany from the annual three-day policy
forum which was launched at the height
of the cold war for the first time since
1991 russia will not be attending dw
will bring you a full coverage from
munich this afternoon
uh one of the people you'll be seeing
lots of in our coverage of the security
conference is our chief political editor
michaela kufner welcome michaela let's
talk about russia no russia delegation
for the first time in 30 years why
yeah that's a big question well clearly
russia is not interested in engaging in
detail on the goings-on not just over
ukraine but also over other
crisis regions there's a lot to talk
about at this munich security conference
but the current standoff which as we
heard not just anthony blinken also the
u.s president fears could tip over into
a hot war at any point
now
is clearly overshadowing every
conversation that is taking place on the
multiple other crises that really need
talking about after all this munich
security conference which is seen most
importantly as a forum where leaders can
meet in these side rooms can have
private conversations out of the
spotlight while us journalists are
talking here in the full glare um of the
public
hasn't really taken place for two years
now so it's about time that these
leaders can meet and with a great
urgency to have such conversations
russia clearly isn't interested in
talking in detail
thank you for that dw chief political
editor michaela kufner at the munich
security conference